alors les trophées du post c'est le
moment que j'attendais on va remettre
nos petits trophées ils sont là sa page
compte sur toi non tu n'auras pas trop
fait et en toi c'est alors les trophées
voici donc il est beau le trophée ba oui
merci
on commence avec le trophée du projet et
meilleur candidat de jeux de télé
regarde
[Musique]
martin le candidat plein d'autodérision
depuis la dernière fois où vous étiez
venus est une superbe et déjà je suis
toujours à 20 m par rapport à il ya deux
ans fait ça pas changé c'est faux de
préciser parce que si je vous regarde
pas leurs dons les yeux faut pas m'en
vouloir
laurent le candidat sans gêne des
problèmes sur les ramblas n'ont jamais
séparé jamie est fouillé j'ai filé mois
la cagnotte et je pars aussi sébastien
le nouveau laurent gerra je sais très
bien imité jean pierre foucault bonsoir
et bienvenue dans qui veut gagner des
millions
[Musique]
j'ai des viticulteurs départ c'est vous
le reconnaissez bonjour et bienvenue
donnée de ce qu'il s'est passé j'ai
bougé alors le premier commence à
retomber vers taba martin martin 3e sans
faute d'accord le 1er 3e marc thomé
infirmiers bataille maintenant le nord
martin s'est voulu envoyer pour de vrai
allez on passe à mombasa au trophée sur
le meilleur chroniqueur de la semaine à
regarder
[Musique]
maxime guinea de plus en plus chemin
pour prouver exécution prague de bâtir
on s'est bien marré mais ce brin de
saisies ces sommets sont attachés à un
telle croissance
[Applaudissements]
jean luc lemoine avec l'histoire du
beurre pour rendre hommage à cette date
dans le public était au début de la
chaîne avec sa plaquette de beurre juste
au moment où s'il a décidé de faire une
pause dans le jeu
[Rires]
[Musique]
gilles verdez qui clashe jean michel
maire rien de plus que moi en ambre
allons pas une passe encore ouais normal
si ça vous semble incroyable des mois
jean-michel que tu nous emmerdes avec ta
bouche que tu vas faire au théâtre avec
ça n'était pas capable d'articuler trois
moutures va nous emmerder chose il
gilles jean luc ok peut dire je t'aime
gilles mais jean-luc ouais mais mes
petits choux matinée
[Applaudissements]